[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
boleto de vuelta soy valentina torre
sánchez y los acompaño el reemplazo de
mi compañera paula jiménez en esta
ocasión vamos a corea del sur donde se
cumplen siete años del naufragio del
transbordador se vuelve el hundimiento
se produjo el 16 de abril de 2014 cuando
el navío se volcó en la costa suroeste
de corea del sur con 476 personas a
bordo entre ellas 325 estudiantes de
secundaria que estaban en un viaje de
estudios casi ninguno de ellos
sobrevivió al hundimiento porque en el
momento del accidente todos los niños
recibieron la orden de permanecer en sus
camarotes mientras el barco naufragaba
esta tragedia nacional que causó la
muerte de 300 cuatro personas no sólo
puso en tela de juicio el sistema hiper
jerárquico de corea del sur sino que dio
origen a una nueva generación de jóvenes
comprometidos políticamente la
generación del 16 de abril muchos de
ellos tienen el deseo de sacudir a una
clase política considerada apática los
corresponsales de france 24 en corea se
desplazaron lanzan una ciudad a pocos
kilómetros de seúl de donde proceden 250
de las
los equipos de rescate los padres y las
autoridades se movilizan a su manera
para superar el trauma siete años
después la investigación sobre las
causas de la catástrofe sigue estancada
veamos la historia
[Música]
tenía miedo de subir hacia barco después
de la muerte de mi amigo puede sonar
extraño y quiero podía oír los gritos de
los niños como en una especie de
alucinación me acordé de esos vídeos de
esto
[Música]
frente a la costa de moco en el sur de
la península de corea
los restos del world son ahora un barco
fantasma siete años después del
naufragio sigue atormentando a las
familias de las víctimas
[Música]
esos nombres entonados una y otra vez a
través de los altavoces son los nombres
de los 250 niños que corea del sur
perdió el 16 de abril de 2014 y
estudiantes de secundaria en un viaje
escolar como todos los años los
familiares de las víctimas vinieron de
toda corea para conmemorar el incidente
[Música]
la señora quien perdió a su hijo mayor
en el hundimiento su nombre era swing
como siempre le dije te quiero que
tengas un buen viaje dios está contigo
rezaré por ti diviértete tributo y
también no te olvides de llamarme pero
nunca recibí esa llamada
ya han pasado siete años pero no puedo
superar el hecho de que mi hijo ya no
está conmigo me parece que fue ayer
cuando lo vi que va a empujar la puerta
de mi casa y entrar en cualquier momento
y ninguno de los padres duerme bien por
las noches porque todos esperan el
regreso de sus hijos también se gustan
mucho
con el tiempo la tristeza de los padres
también se convirtió en ira
las familias debían ir a depositar
flores al mar en el lugar del
hundimiento pero en el acto descubren
que la embarcación que les entregaron
era de los guardacostas los mismos a los
que las familias acusan de haber
estropeado la operación de rescate en
y lloraba
es la tripulación de este barco en la
que permaneció inerte con los zapatos
bien lustrados mientras él se hundía
como puede decir que es un país justo y
hago un poco más y nos hundirán en el
cbol también tuvo mancha atarán que hay
aquí
la ceremonia será finalmente cancelada
en ese momento las operaciones de
rescate fueron un rotundo fracaso
el cbol tardó 2 horas y 30 minutos en
hundirse ante la mirada impotente de
helicópteros y cámaras de televisión
[Música]
se llevará un total de 304 pasajeros con
el jean guy jean estaba a bordo del pse
world el día del accidente es una de las
pocas sobrevivientes
[Música]
con mis amigos estábamos en una gran
sala con capacidad para unas 30 personas
el barco se inclinó a todos caemos del
lado de las ventanas la puerta estaba
aquí las ventanas allí pero se inclinó
así hasta ese momento no éramos
conscientes de lo que estaba pasando nos
reíamos nos preguntábamos qué estaba
pasando
de repente oímos un ruido de olas desde
el fondo de la sala me encontré con el
agua hasta las rodillas pero nos
ordenaron que nos quedáramos quietos y
no pensé en salir de allí entonces oí
los gritos de mis amigos y los
compartimientos se derrumbaron nos
encontramos en una situación en la que
no teníamos otra opción
teníamos que escapar casi en el último
momento una amiga me ayudó desde arriba
o no
curicó
es difícil de creer lo más difícil es
haber perdido a mis años
muchos de los sobrevivientes han quedado
con graves traumas que a veces los han
llevado a intentos de suicidio jiang a
hellín convirtió sus miedos en una
vocación ahora es enfermera y espera
convertirse en bombero para salvar vidas
para los familiares de las víctimas la
vida solo tiene un propósito destapar
toda la verdad sobre el desastre del pse
world sobrecarga y trabajos ilegales
realizados en el barco salida con niebla
colisión a pesar de varias
investigaciones las causas exactas del
accidente siguen sin estar claras en
pleno hundimiento el capitán es uno de
los primeros en escapar del barco porque
se ha ordenado a los pasajeros que
permanecieran en sus camarotes
[Música]
esta zona
inubicable durante siete horas en el
momento de los hechos que hacía la ex
presidenta de la república mientras se
producía una de las peores catástrofes
de la historia del país
en la sede de su asociación las familias
de las víctimas preparan una
manifestación en seúl estos distintivos
amarillos se han convertido en el
símbolo de su lucha
las exigencias de la señora kim no han
cambiado desde la tragedia del seaworld
pero cuanto más tiempo pasa más siento
que mi hijo me va a preguntar a mamá lo
que ha pasado porque me pasó esto
necesito saberlo para poder responderle
cuando lo vuelva a ver
el presidente de la república nos
prometió que haría todo lo posible para
que se descubriera la verdad en este
caso pero esta promesa aún no se ha
cumplido por eso hacemos subir nuestra
voz
es necesario conocer la verdad para
avanzar
y castigar a los culpables y construir
una mejor sociedad éste intentó abordar
el cicu
créate una danza vega triste que te une
dónde puedo encontrar los carteles de la
manifestación
están por ahí o sí gracias
entre los participantes esta política de
24 años conocida por ser el miembro más
joven del partido en el gobierno
entró en política tras la tragedia y
pertenece a lo que en corea del sur se
llama la generación según jóvenes
ciudadanos comprometidos y movilizados
por el cambio
[Música]
estamos obligados a ser el desastre no
es sólo un triste incidente es un
acontecimiento clave en la destitución
del ex presidente cuando el pueblo se
reunió para impugnar al gobierno y creo
que la generación según la desempeñó un
papel importante en la situación
política de la época seguro sea de cada
forma los jóvenes pudieron ser los
árbitros de un gobierno corrupto pero
que golpean hong kong naturalmente esto
despertó nuestro interés por la política
y nos hizo reflexionar sobre el papel
del gobierno en el camino a seguir para
nuestro país somos trabaje de woods no
voy a saber callar para nuevos ingresos
en la crisis total awacs
también
utilizando el plato vacío santo
por las restricciones relacionadas con
la pandemia los manifestantes se
distribuyen a los lados de la carretera
que lleva a la casa azul la residencia
del presidente surcoreano una
movilización silenciosa todos blandiendo
el mismo mensaje una vez más recordamos
el pse wall de nuevo esta noche la
señora kim será una de las últimas en
abandonar el lugar
en corea del sur la catástrofe del pse
world no sólo provocó una agitación
política también sacudió el sistema
hiper jerárquico del país
podrían haberse salvado las víctimas si
no hubieran seguido ciegamente las
órdenes de permanecer en sus camarotes
[Música]
en esta escuela secundaria técnica del
sureste de corea del sur
el profesor 15-1 conmemora el séptimo
aniversario del naufragio con algunos
consejos inusuales
han tenido interés
lo más lamentable del hundimiento del
seaworld fue que los estudiantes
sintieron el peligro pero se quedaron en
sus camarotes por la información errónea
que les dieron y ese es el problema de
nuestro sistema educativo que enseñamos
hacia el pasivo a obedecer
en el futuro incluso en nuestra clase no
quiero que te quedes pasivo estudia por
tu propia interés actúa por tu propio
interés construyen su propio futuro
a pesar de este consejo la clase
permanece en silencio
el profesor kim sabe que no podrá hacer
cambiar de opinión a la gente fácilmente
y en corea del sur la sociedad y la
educación se basan en la autoridad para
preservar esta autoridad se han
establecido muchas normas innecesarias
los estudiantes están encerrados en
estas reglas y no tienen espacio para
usar sus mentes por ejemplo se les
obliga a llevar un uniforme un tipo de
peinado e incluso el color de los
zapatos eso tiene que cambiar
ah
esta mañana el profesor kim decidió
llevar a sus alumnos al puerto de pemex
uno de los lugares más cercanos al
naufragio en el momento del accidente
los primeros cuerpos fueron llevados a
esta zona
me entristece estar aquí
frente al lugar donde ocurrió el
accidente y espero que descansen en paz
al chico
[Música]
es un trauma cada vez que vengo aquí es
lo mismo y tanto vídeo
con el tiempo el muelle se ha convertido
en un lugar de peregrinación para los
surcoreanos
[Música]
los niños desaparecidos eran de la
ciudad de anshan a 30 kilómetros al sur
de seúl y de una de las escuelas
secundarias
aquí la llegada de la primavera y de los
días bonitos es también sinónimo de
dolor
[Música]
el municipio acaba de inaugurar un
centro educativo en el interior aulas re
construidas a partir de las utilizadas
por las víctimas del fútbol las mismas
mesas rayadas las mismas pizarras los
mismos casilleros para los alumnos las
familias también trajeron recuerdos de
sus hijos
el director del centro perdió a su hijo
en el accidente
con este nuevo edificio el señor ion
espera aumentar la concientización
hoy en día en corea del sur donde los
alumnos de primaria tienen que asistir a
clases de supervivencia y solo pueden
realizar un pequeño número de viajes
escolares esto demuestra que la atención
se centra cada vez más en la seguridad
me gustaría que este centro educativo y
estas aulas se convirtieran en un lugar
de recuerdo y compasión pero también que
provocarán un pensamiento crítico
con este centro debemos ir más allá de
la simple labor de memoria y crear
esperanza
sin embargo fue difícil para los
visitantes contener sus emociones
no los conozco pero cuando vi la foto de
este chico me recordó a mi hijo es muy
triste
es un accidente que podría haber
ocurrido a mi familia
han pasado muchos años a veces olvide lo
que pasó a veces no quiero recordar pero
no podemos olvidar
williams
[Música]
la tragedia del wall fue un vector de
cambio para una sociedad cuya rigidez se
vio sacudida por la tragedia pero siete
años después corea del sur aún no ha
conseguido hacer el duelo
[Música]
gracias por acompañarnos en esta misión
de boleto de vuelta recuerden que pueden
repetir este y otros programas en
nuestra web france24 puntocom
[Música]